i i toured a bottom set uh at cranbrook
school last year bottom set uh year 10
um and i i tried a few activities out
and it was a wonderful
opportunity actually teaching a bottom
set because they were the no maths
students who were going to give up and
so there really weren't many
expectations i didn't have to keep up
with a particular cohort or a scheme of
work or whatever and in fact i went
completely off peace because it's not
that no one cared what i was doing but i
wasn't really that accountable so that's
ideal teaching as far as i'm concerned
you know just completely blank sheet
and it gives you a chance to create and
re-engage and my focus for that year was
to these these kids have been kind of
mathematically abused for like years and
years every time they've
done any methods that failed failed
failed failed failed and i just wanted
to give them some sense of success some
sense of
confidence and see whether i could build
that um so anyway
oh yeah this is the kind of student that
this these guys were how i see math word
problems if you have four pencils and i
have seven apples how many pancakes will
fit on the roof purple because aliens
don't wear hats
so i quite like that
so anyway it was a breath of fresh air
um i'm going to show you what happened
so the first five weeks
we basically i i offered them i said
look we can do consumer arithmetic and
that's something which is really useful
and it will be really useful for you and
your future you can actually use this or
we can learn how to count
in ancient mine and then we can learn
how to count in a completely
random number base and you can learn
some really really abstract maths which
even the four units students in year 12
don't get or don't get taught what would
you prefer
so what do you reckon they chose
they chose the abstract maths that was
what was engaging for them they weren't
interested in a utilitarian approach you
know that wasn't of interest which i
think is
quite
um pertinent because a lot of maths uh
silvis writers and a lot of influential
maths educators feel that we justify our
profession by making it useful and
that's the only way to engage students
it isn't
um here's the end of the five weeks this
is hugo and hugh's presentation oh no it
isn't what's that is that
maybe i have to click on it
there we go
so this was their assessment in front of
vips including
12.
here we have
what base 10 looks like
and here's what base 12 looks like so
i'll take a simple unboxing
in bags
this is
one in the ten thousands columns one in
the one thousands column one the one
with the one two one and the ones and we
say this as eleven thousand one hundred
and eleven
but in base ten this is one twenty
thousand seven hundred thirty six
once one thousand seven hundred twenty
eight one one hundred and forty four one
twelve and one one then you'd add them
all together to get
twenty two thousand six 621
and yeah that's
that's that
okay have a 12 works in base 12 there
are 12 symbols they are 0 1 2 3 4 5 6 7
8 9. until
a and b which have changed symbols the
reason there is a and b is because we
have to run out of symbols because we
already have used one at zero one and
zero would be twelve in base twelve
and
one twelve and zero units while in base
ten it would be
one ten and zero units
example one hundred and best twelve is
eight
four
because there are eight twelves and four
units
you said there's twelve squares in the
base twelve how many symbols are there
best ten ten one
about one two three four five six seven
eight
mathematical questions
okay any more questions that you can use
i i've got one um
are there any advantages of using base
12 rather than base 10
well yeah because it has
many more like factors there's
is
i'm not sure how much of that you could
hear but that was pretty unbelievable
these are kids who have failed every
maths exam they've sat there bottom
bottom sets they're
about to go on and do no maths they're
not apparently motivated to do anything
in year 10 they're just in the classroom
and yeah that after five weeks you can
see even though that's not on the
syllabus it ticks so many boxes in terms
of place position and exponentiation and
um what was he talking about at the end
he was talking about factors i mean it's
really quite
amazing how all of that maths comes out
of this project um
the other thing is you know i think that
as maths teachers we sometimes are so
obsessed with getting through the
syllabus i haven't got time for it i
haven't got time for it i've got to get
through the syllabus i've got to get
through the service we haven't got time
we've got to test them and it sort of
goes on and on and in the end we're
actually the whole point of the syllabus
is they're written
so that they're written in a way to try
and encourage maths teachers to teach
conceptually and yet paradoxically
they end up you know you get a textbook
which tries to follow the syllabus and
then math teachers try to follow the
textbook and then they feel obliged to
do every single exercise in the textbook
and they set homework because they can't
get through it and then you've got
little year sevens who get smashed in
their first year with all this homework
and it's not education is it i mean
that's really not what we're trying to
well it's not what education should be
about so i think we sometimes need to
take a step back and be confident to go
off-piste
knowing that we can still teach the same
concepts and actually probably more
effectively and quicker um
so by the end of this project it filled
them with a sense of self-esteem that
they could actually
talk about number bases and they
understood different number bases in a
way that other students in the school
didn't and it was really quite high
brown maths and that really picked them
up and we put it on the portal so that
everyone could see their presentations
it was really quite a nice little
project and it oh there it is again um
comes from this guy um well it doesn't
but
those of you who at my era
remember doing number bases in primary
school with these things called dean's
blogs after zoltan deans who actually
died this year at the ripe old age of
79. i'll just read you his obituary
referred to as a maverick mathematician
zoltan and other hungarian
introduced revolutionary ideas um of
learning complex mathematical concepts
in fun ways such as games and dance so
that children were often unaware they
were learning mathematics they were
having a wonderful exciting creative
time and longing for more he
invented the dean's multi-base
arithmetic blocks and many other games
and materials that embodied mathematical
concepts what's nice about this and i
remember learning it it's not just place
position it's also links in with visual
learners and volume and surface area and
dimensions it's it's actually brilliant
um it's such a shame it's gone out of
syllabuses as such but you can still
teach it